hey everyone it's sarah the registry
nurse rn.com and in this video i'm going
to talk about some things that every
nurse should know about their patient
now this isn't necessarily an exhaustive
list of everything that you need to know
about a patient before you actually
provide care to them it's just really to
give you a general idea of things that
you should know before you go in that
room and see that patient because for
example let's say your patient is
critically ill well some of these points
i'm going to list you really want to go
in more detail with them versus a
patient who's less critical you can
maybe actually skim over some of these
points and this is really going to vary
depending on your nursing specialty and
the type of patient population you're
providing care to so one important thing
you want to know about your patient is
their diagnosis why are they there
receiving treatment also you want to be
familiar with their health history
specifically a focused health history
like are they diabetic because that
tells you as a nurse okay this patient
may have issues with hypo or
hyperglycemia i'm going to have to check
their blood sugar we got to watch their
diet etc next you want to be familiar
with a patient's allergies because you
don't want to receive an order for a
medication on a patient then find out
they're allergic to it and then have to
call the physician back and get an order
for a new medication you also want to be
familiar with the patient's code status
are they a full code or are they a do
not resuscitate because you never know
when a patient is going to code i have
seen patients who are about to be
discharged they've been cleared by their
doctor and all of a sudden they code so
you want to definitely be familiar with
that next you want to be familiar with
the patient's lab and testing results
and looking for anything that is really
important for that patient based on
what's going on with them so look at
their trending labs let's say you're
monitoring the hematocrit and hemoglobin
is it going up or is it going down plus
you want to be familiar with any pending
labs the patient may need so you can
make sure that those are collected on
time
and make sure that you're aware of any
pending procedures the patient needs to
have like some procedures require the
patient to be nothing by mouth so you
need to make sure they're not eating and
you may have to do a pre-op checklist
and then that ties me to my next point
you want to be familiar with the
patient's diet status first of all can
they eat
and if they can what kind of diet are
they following are they following a
cardiac diet a renal diet or they have
to have a soft diet or because they have
swallowing difficulty so you want to be
familiar with all those things you also
want to have this baseline understanding
about your patient for instance you want
to have a baseline about what you should
expect out of their mental status their
vital signs their rhythm what are they
running have they been running sinus
rhythm or sinus tac atrial fib atrial
flutter and you want to have an
understanding about their abilities can
they get up go to the bathroom without
assistance or are they a total care
where you need to do everything for them
venus access is also important you want
to know do they have venus access if so
where is it at and what size do they
have and when was it inserted in case
you may have to change it out depending
on your hospital protocol and this ties
in with medications you want to be
familiar with how that patient is
supposed to receive medications like the
time frame and if there's any time
sensitive medications or medications
that require you collect lab work before
you actually give the medication along
with any prn medications the patient's
taking let's say they're having pain so
when was their last dose of pain
medication because the patient may ask
you when can i have my pain medication
next plus you want to be familiar with
any type of fluids the patient may have
running this can be continuous fluids
like normal saline or this could even be
some type of drip that you may have to
titrate based on the patient's vital
signs or even lab results another thing
you want to be familiar with are the
devices that your patient has and this
could be internal devices or external
devices and typically the more critical
your patient is the more devices or
equipment they're going to be using so
you want to be familiar with if your
patient has a pacemaker if they have
let's say a sub-q port do they have any
wound vacs drains or feeding tubes in
addition you'll want to be familiar with
other physician groups that have been
consulted to help take care of that
patient because let's say your patient
starts having a cardiac problem well if
you see that cardiology has been
consulted you'll know which group to
call so you can help get care for your
patient and this leads me into my next
point you'll want to be familiar with
the patient's plan of care and it's
really helpful if you go look in the
physician's progress notes and just read
what
physicians have been saying about the
patient and the whole treatment plan for
them because that'll help give you an
understanding about where we're going
with this patient's care and finally you
want to be familiar with the patient's
support system this could be family or
friends whoever the patient has
designated as someone that they want to
know about their health now that was a
lot of stuff that you have to remember
about a patient and you're probably
thinking okay how in the world do i get
this information well there's typically
two ways one way is through report where
you have that handoff communication
whenever you're taking over for another
nurse they give it to you but sometimes
you know you may not get that
information and you can find that other
information you didn't get in the
patient's chart so that is how you get
the information but how do you keep this
information straight because you have
all these other patients that you have
to remember other things on so one thing
i have found that's really helpful is to
use some type of report sheet template
and actually have some report sheet
templates that you could look at to
maybe get some ideas and what you can do
is you can have this piece of paper
write the information down whenever
you're getting report and then
as you find out that information add to
it and then periodically just check it
to help refresh your memory on which
patient has this and which patient needs
that and that can really help guide you
throughout your day okay so those are
some things that you need to know about
your patient as the nurse now if you
would like to watch some more videos
let's say new nurse tips etc you can
access the link in the youtube
description below